a picture of 24 year old ahmad assadi is
laid next to the grave of his friend
abdullah
who was killed by israeli forces in
march
now they're both buried in the same
cemetery a few meters from each other
both were members of the islamic jihad
party in jenin in the north of the
occupied west bank
mourners tell us assadi went to confront
israeli forces when they raided the
refugee camp early on saturday
[Music]
he took me to the hospital in the
morning to check on my arm when he heard
the israeli army was in the camp he
wanted to confront them later i called
him and he said he was surrounded then
he didn't pick up the phone i saw videos
of him on the ground
he was always with me too i used to try
to convince him to stay safe all of his
friends became martyrs he was sick of
this life
the palestinian health ministry say 30
palestinians from the occupied west bank
have been killed since the beginning of
the year
most during confrontations with israeli
forces
just 10 days ago palestinians in the
jeannine refugee camp married 17 year
old senator
after he was shot by the israeli forces
fire
now they're mourning the loss of ahmad
sadi and remembering abdullah
who was killed by israeli forces fire 40
days ago palestinians here are telling
us that the israeli occupation has left
them with one option
to fight it
the israeli army say two palestinians
were arrested and plans made to demolish
the home of rat hasem he's the gunman
suspected of killing three israelis in
an attack on a bar in tel aviv on
thursday
his family have been summoned for
questioning by the israeli military but
told the jazeera they don't intend to go
two of the four attacks in israel in the
past three weeks were by palestinians
from the jeanine area
palestinians considered jinin a
stronghold for resistance to the israeli
occupation and it's estimated that there
are thousands of guns here
during the second antifather the janine
refugee camp was the scene of one of the
deadliest trades by the israeli military
[Applause]
twenty years later without a state or
freedom from occupation palestinians
here say that battle isn't over
ibrahim al-jazeera you occupied west
bank